[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight we have exclusive
never-before-seen messages text messages
from inside the FBI these texts are
among the thousands sent between FBI
agents Peter Strock and Lisa page
between February and September of 2016
a lot of them are interesting here's a
key text the agents did exactly what you
would hope agents would never do they
express concern about whether Hillary
Clinton if she was elected president
would take revenge against the FBI for
the crime of investigating her in
exchange from February of 2016 agent
page told agent Sturrock quote one more
thing she might be our next president
the last thing you need us going in
there loaded for bear you think she's
gonna remember or care that it was more
DOJ than the FBI struck told page that
he agreed in other words political
concerns were at top of mind as they
investigated this politician Hillary
Clinton congressman trey Gowdy of South
Carolina chairs the Oversight Committee
in the house he's a member of the
Intelligence Committee and he joins us
to react congressman thanks for coming
on our circle are we reading too deeply
into the exchange we just put on the
screen do you think well I don't think
so book is you you read that one in
isolation if you if you read all the
text it's clear that they did not want
her charged they wanted her to be the
president I states they really really
didn't well Donald Trump repeated
presidents and they concede throughout
these texts that they did things
differently in this investigation from
any other investigation that they were
part of so when I what I don't
understand is even if you're watching
this at home and you think well I wanted
Hillary to win too and I don't like
Donald Trump - shouldn't she be a little
concerned maybe actually terrified that
FBI agents conducting a criminal
investigation into a politician we're
worried about the political elements of
the investigation that's not supposed to
happen is it what you may remember as I
do Jim Comey telling us that the FBI
doesn't give a whit about politics he he
loved to tell us how apolitical the
Bureau was and here we have these texts
of course our friends on the Left say
well these are texts between two lovers
yeah that's right you're much more
likely to tell the truth when you don't
think anybody else is watching this I
think is the unvarnished truth of how
they viewed both her/him and the
investigation and how they wanted it to
turn out
keep in mind Tucker all of this was done
before she was ever interviewed so the
fix was in unfortunately before they
even interviewed the target of the
investigation what does it tell you
about what they thought of Hillary
Clinton they believed if she became
president she would punish our chief law
enforcement agency for investigating her
what does that say about their view of
her or their understanding of her it's
either that or I think another
reasonable construction could be that
she would reward the DOJ thinking it was
more DOJ lawyers that concluded she
should not be charged as opposed to the
FBI and that's actually how I read it
that she would give more credit to the
Department of Justice you know keep in
mind is reading these texts it doesn't
appear that anyone wanted her charged
before they even knew what she was going
to say I read that to be they were
concerned DOJ would get the credit for
taking care of her more than the bureau
would you've taken an enormous amount of
abuse as have your colleagues on the
Intelligence Committee as has this
channel for daring to report this news
as if asking questions about the
behavior of law enforcement officials is
unpatriotic how do you respond to that
Tucker there's no one in Congress that
has more respect for law enforcement I
spent 18 years working with them it's
the best 18 years of my professional
life and always will be I love law
enforcement which is why these techs
break my heart bias is insidious bias is
the one thing in a courtroom Tucker the
judge will give you the broadest leeway
because it infects and instructs every
decision you make when you are bias for
or against someone right so when I see
manifests bias you know think back to
other important cases in our country's
history mark Fuhrman got in trouble not
so much for working the crime scene but
because of racial
pathetic his career that's how seriously
we take bias I don't know why the left
can't concede in this case that these
two agents should never have been part
of investigating her case what you would
think that Democrats at some point it
would occur to them that maybe most FBI
agents aren't liberal they're probably
conservative I'd be willing to bet money
on that so if you allow the FBI to let
their agents make decisions on the basis
of their political beliefs maybe that's
gonna hurt Democrats at some point maybe
all of us have a real interest in clean
and ethical government but they don't
seem to have an interest in that right
now why I don't know I don't like bias
I don't like political bias manifesting
itself in an embezzlement case I don't
like it in a bank robbery case this was
a incredibly politically charged case as
was and is the Russia investigation so
politics and political bias is even more
important in a case like this IIIi don't
know why the left is straining to
minimize the manifest bias that was
exhibited by these agents I I don't get
it I'm sorry to say so you got some
totally unprincipled people up there
with you I'm sorry about that
congressman thank you